Here are our final answers. Great work if you got those correct. This cube root
and this 5th root might have been tricky, so if you struggled with them, that's
okay. For the first one, we split 32 into 2 times 16. The square root of 16
equals 4, and the square root of x squared is x, and the square root of y
squared is y. This leaves us with a 2 in the radical, which gives us our final
result. For the second one, we want to split up 75 into 3 times 25. The square
root of 25 equals 5, and then we leave the 3 inside of the square root since
it's not a perfect square. Next, we use our idea of power divided by root. We
have a square root, so we want to take this power and divide it by 2, 3 divided
by 2 equals 1 with a remainder of 1. So, one a will be on the outside, and one
a will be on the inside. For b, we'll have 8 divided by 2 which is 4, so e to
the 4. And finally, for c, we'll have c squared since c to the 4th divided by 2
equals c squared. This is our final result. For the next problem, we rewrite a
as 2 cubed. We know that cube root of 2 cubed is just 2 since that this factor
appears three times. Now we us power divided by route to simplify each of these
variables. 5 divided by 3 is 1 remainder 2. For c, 4 divided by 3 equals 1
remainder 1. And for d, we have 6 divided by 3 which equals d squared, and no
d's inside the radicals since the remainder is 0. And finally, for our last
one, we can't take the 5th root of 36, since we don't have a factor that
appears 5 times. Nothing simplifies. But for our variable factors, we can
simplify 10 divided by 5 equals 2. So, we'll have w squared, with no w's inside
our radical, since the remainder is 0. For x, we'll have 6 divided by 5 which
equals 1 remained 1. And for y, we'll have 12 divided 5 which equals 2
remainder 2. Here's our final answer.